bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono fra vigente ed oggi
siamo tornati su google field è stato
talmente figo come gioco che non potevo
non rifarci epico fatevi provare a
vedere se stavolta riescono a cercare
qualcosa andiamo con name apollo quindi
devo trovare quella gente che si chiama
paul su google
paul mccartney l'ottavo mica solo
ricorda qualcuno passo ridicola
[Musica]
quel paul walker che il quarto podda e
iii e che sono partiti da dio non ho mai
col 46 un record non mi è mai successo
un pour parler
ap paul newman ski così si fa più male
di cibo che culo record assoluto di
google film dei ragazzi non lo so
l'ultima non lo so non lo so [ __ ]
non ho idea non ne conoscevo 1 all is
gay ma come possa averlo scritto per
scherzo va bene si è scoperto ragazzi
che il football è gay
eccolo stato tratto sembra chiellini
senza un apparente motivo violent
amazing liz taylor swift speak sexual
engaged significa fidanzata ed è il
primo perché tutti si fanno i cazzi di
taylor swift gay non è dei blonde ma
[ __ ] cosa era morta sposata sta
avendo degli appuntamenti con selena
gomez no perché sarebbe morta a questo
punto ci avrei pensato io a singola
trump support ea perché gesù a perché
gesù have played pokémon go croci fit ed
non so come si dice ah ma
a tattoo perché gesù ha un tatuaggio
perché gesù a un lasso perché gesù tuo
thing as long è perché gesù ai capelli
lunghi navarra scarseggiavano di
parrucchieri e come tu hai perché deve
venire due volte perché è morto perché i
francesi sono così gay primo closing at
the finals che peccato ma gustosi nostro
rulfi minchia vedono tutti di buon
occhio i francesi arrogant lacy depresse
voglio la stessa domanda sugli italiani
per l'amor di dio può oggi sul perché le
domande su gesù gesù walk on water
secondo resuscitare win the lottery
smith
chi cremo a burrito oggi su mettere un
burrito del forno a microonde va bene
[Musica]
[Applauso]
sports archei perché gay
va bene con qualsiasi cosa life sposar
band ma come dangerous d'angelo niente
aic ha tradito la mia ragazza con attesa
erba non so come si dice guida gae macro
another girl with my ex ma [ __ ]
quanto può essere stupido with my best
friend e quella è uscita la l'affluenza
con un po worker quindi una mucca che
lavora con sua mamma va bene con una
prostituta con una ragazza più bella con
sua stress ma bellissimo ragazzino non
ho parole belli questa era stupenda
posso mangiare la mia merda non vengono
né davvero a città non andava bene
pubblico bene ok dong ma come quel c'è
gente che cerca su google possono
mangiare il miocardio poveri cani ma i
cat
va bene che le it my brother non è my
brother mais bada che schifo santo iddio
mais cubi my fit boxe burgers bookers
sarebbero caccole la centa bruce non è
il primo veramente bruce willis chi
caccia il primo bruce bruce lago di
garda springsteen si che così si scrive
così a chimica è il primo bruce primo
c'è bruce lee e sotto ma veramente bruce
lee bruce qui da niente non c'è un blues
la non c'è non ne sapevo le gas plus
amica bruce wayne capirla i pesci fanno
mai la cacca di casa fanno i pesci
dormono anno 7 ma veramente fa non ci
credo a nega ma veramente
smettono di crescere blink che ci
sbattono gli occhi si annoiano i saziano
si stancano di nuotare anthony di
francesco non funziona antony morato
morata hopkins adesso solo lui entra di
antonio non ne conoscevo uno va bene sa
però solo king sul dai cui dovrei
andarmene show dai quiz youtube sicuro
che c'è non c'è internet school
no perché le donne secondo fa vj perché
le donne vanno in due al bagno così c'è
going to you are so sexy io so sexy
niente allora perché le donne tradiscono
perché le donne temono perché hanno il
periodo perché indossano e reggiseni
indosseranno reggiseni per ascoltare
buona musica per che cazzo vuoi che
indossino dei reggiseni per che bevono
il succo di mirtillo vabbè perché gli
uomini non lo fanno d'oro di ice man bed
and smell zampagni allora odore di carne
o d'oro bene o d'oro di merda odor di
topo o d'oro di fumo d'oro di gas o
d'oro di problemi o d'oro di merda o
d'oro di tosto mica mi fa mai ragazzi
dio donarvi di sentire cazzo sono
proprio di toast e astronauti pisciano
di pop hit small cui pagano le tasse
arca miniato sai che imu devono pagare
per il sistema solare justin ragazzi la
prima cosa che state pensando e
sicuramente just in time
giusto in tempo non è così justin
timberlake justin timberlake e secondo
chi cazzo sarà il primo già a e giorgio
through the house justin trudeau justin
wilson già senso justin aspetta a justin
bistrot non funziona justin bieber a
cazzo non avevo venuto in mente justin
bieber dreads justin bieber love
yourself di so cool tour sting e cool
puzzare è cool
be famous and go to school to school i
school is good to school say it's cool
tu sei cool il culto b day
ciò dà il sel ma dovrei vendere la mia
macchina questa e l'avevo fatta tra
l'altro mi ricordo più
ma i found myself fondo io su cavani
ormai iphone
niente mariko doppio house non mi
ricordavo più un cazzo
ai ragazzi rispetto al momento in cui
metteranno anche fa vj in google fidia
dunque questo purtroppo cola chiellini
devo renderlo più chiellini di quanto
non lo sia eccoci qua adesso quale a
chiellini ma ovviamente sto scherzando
si tira gazzoli spero che vi sia
piaciuto come se si raggiungerà un
commento è un mi piace anche a pagina di
facebook e con descrizione ci sono
significativi ci vediamo fosse un video
beh ragazzi